[Music]
how many guys
wish you were taller not me baby not you
i'm not talking to you
just maybe two three inches two three so
how tall are you right now five nine
five nine so you want to be like right
below six
depends am i am i able how many times do
i get to choose what the [ __ ] just make
up your [ __ ] mind
what was the terms i already said it cuz
you know like for girls they can go
uh they can like oh i wanna do my lips
right and it goes
oh i [ __ ] up then go those are fillers
girls could cheeto with heels too
because girls put the heels on and all
of a sudden they make them girls are 5
10
for the night no but i'm saying this so
for plastic surgery right like they can
they can correct
their corrections okay for me i might be
like all right i'll make me sick
i go i go try out for the nba nah that
ain't good maybe bring it down to 60. do
you think you're going to try this those
are good for mbhs
and it's just height that god hit like
that
i'll try the different heights and i'll
try different things you know what i
mean
i always said that this world wasn't
ready for me to be six foot if it was if
i was six you'd be [ __ ] it up
damn it should be over what would you do
whole [ __ ] would be different if i was
sick
i'll tell you right now i'm five seven
and a half okay
i can't take it
yeah i want to try being tall to see if
i like that or
what i'm at right now for you though
like six feet right
i mean yeah for ages like six foot like
that be great like that's the ideal high
height not just height but like your
body like
awareness and just kind of oh dude it's
so different your whole life is
it's so different i love it me
[Music]
i know i'm unique i mean what would you
say in the percentile of women you're
like probably top 58
98 yeah have you ever been to a concert
and you're like
god dammit i just want to be inches tall
are you taller than bart
yes two inches but i wonder if it'll fit
that's a lot i wonder if it'll affect
like the certain things that i do for
play and all that
like if it's better or worse that's what
i want to do your center of balance is
probably gonna be yeah that's the thing
because my
taller friends have uh balance problems
yeah
but six foot six foot solid you know
that's like a seven foot you might be a
little what depends on what sport or
what you're trying to do
because everything is completely
different boards and stuff like that but
then there are
big wave surfers that are tall as [ __ ]
and then they can do it too
so and it depends it depends on just the
person some people are just clumsy no
matter
how short how tall that's why i want to
be in that body
and then like see what's driving what's
crazy
is we're all like what if what if and
jill's like yeah that's right
oh yeah like it's all true but i don't
i don't i don't i don't envy it i think
i'm i'm the same as dante like five
seven
and a half jokes yeah
i like my height i'm short i'm 5'4 but
i like it i like your height too i
better lie you better like what you got
yeah that's true that's true that's the
truth
because i can i can affect my height
with like i could wear heels every
single day if i want
yeah they're girls that do that oh yeah
because it would be the same height when
you wear heels
guys i'm still shorter than you but but
that's also not like real real height
right you know i mean like when you're
when you're actually this and you live
and breathe this
your whole life is different you know
it's true but some girls wear heels and
lifts and wedges
every day so they're essentially [ __ ]
yeah but they're essentially that hype
but they can't jump in the water and
swim like michael phelps like he has a
size 15 feet they're not going to do
athletic stuff
but they're functioning in the world as
a person who's five seven they get a
taste of it more than we do
you know it's crazy unless you're
pregnant can you just be wearing
i think he's five eight with heels
though
like five two back in the day the guys
were wearing hills that's who invented
heels
guys yeah platforms right those french
politicians
no there was this girl that we met in
korea and everywhere we were going we're
walking a lot
like a lot and every single day she was
wearing heels and i'm like don't your
feet hurt and she was like
oh no these are my most comfortable like
shoes like i can't do tennis shoes like
for her
heels are like shoes like tennis shoes
yeah just
like all right super comfortable and we
were hiking up like hills and [ __ ] and
she was
those chunky those chunky ugly sneakers
are in for like guys and girls and that
can give you
guys two inches and give you two inches
at least i mean that's
five seven five nine is a different
place it is a different place
that's true but yeah uh what if i told
you there is a
limb lengthening surgery that you could
do i don't want to do it you wouldn't
want to do it would you would you
do it i'm out i'm out glitching they
those were little people originally and
it was a big thing i talked to other you
know little people like
you can't say yeah but so they're saying
and they're there's the people that
don't like it because they're like
you're just dissing everybody else like
you think there's a deformity when we're
like
it's not yeah i don't know
so they improved on this surgery
procedure yeah so some some guy from
dallas
uh alfonso flores uh age 28
wanted to be taller and it wasn't like
he needed the surgery it was just an
elective surgery he was like
i ever since age 12 i wanted to be
taller and he's a basketball fan so he's
like i just want to be like at least six
feet
guess how tall he was before surgery six
two
no oh that'd be funny eleven he's
already tall
oh god and he's like i want to be
two inches like the girls that have the
double d's and they're like i want these
i know
what are you doing i bet when he wakes
up he's probably [ __ ] six feet
probably oh yeah you shrink a little bit
right there you did it
that's crazy yeah that's crazy so he he
broke his uh what is it the femur yeah
that's right
to play devil's advocate though if you
are a die-hard basketball
fan inches do matter like the difference
a game play between someone six six and
six seven
completely different game he's a fan and
not even like a professional i know
but i'm just saying i'm just saying just
if i were to have to have his back
there is game-changing differences
between a 511 player and a six player
he's only a fan yes he's just a fan a
pro he's not a professional also depends
there's some
there's some it depends on you it
depends on you as a player yeah
it's like you can do us for two and two
inches like you still oh he plays
your shot's still bad yeah you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah but he's still 5-11 though
i know 5-11 and a half yeah so here's
alfonso flores with his doctor and this
is before
the surgery so he's 5 11 right here
right five alone
if he shaved his head he's five eleven
but he's already six feet with his hair
six feet true and then here's six one
alfonso flores oh wait what the [ __ ]
that looks like six four it does look
like he gained more than two inches
is a lot though two inches wow right
there that is a lot
bam but the picture is different like a
different angle different true oh he's a
little more forward on this instead of
back pressed
against yeah he looks more confident oh
where did that come from
you sound more confident i don't know if
it's worth it though
cut your legs off and try i mean your
bone isn't the same
yeah i'm like he's gonna try you think
about if you try to do a cut
and you can't do it you're going to
break your legs
there's uh the doctor did say like
there's only so much you can do
before the rehab is going to be more
extensive like you literally have to
relearn to walk and all these things
worth it at two inches he was able to
walk within 24 hours he was able to
kind of start he and he did say alfonso
did say that it didn't hurt as much as
he thought it would like the rehab
that doesn't mean anything how much did
it cost hey they didn't mention the cost
didn't mention the cost
but hold on a second are you gonna do
your arms and stuff too just your legs
oh right right because
now you're just two inches longer his
arms look really good though
it matches because he's already tall
it's true true
imagine a 5'4 like imagine jason chen or
somebody
that becomes six feet because you guys
[ __ ] he's like walking on stilts dude
yeah that's true it's just you gotta do
your arms too yeah do your arms
and it's only two inches though so i
don't think it should change too much
and not only do you have to do that you
also have to do the other limb like this
part too right
because i imagine if you only extend
your femur then wouldn't you have a
short
you might have long what did they extend
on them oh here's some pictures of the
surgery this is him
going in look at his knees wait which
one did he do all right
here we go oh it's steamers oh yeah so
it looks like it obviously it's broken
here and then there's some [ __ ] over
here with some nails
and some [ __ ] over here with some nails
and then this this white metal thing
right here it's a metal rod
that goes inside your bone whoa oh and
then this little gap right here
they add in like some uh some bone some
no tissue and then they kind of rebuild
that now
and they grow regrow your your body i
definitely i definitely don't have that
advantage
because i can i'm visualizing all of it
right now
i feel it in my legs it hurts uh he
should have replaced it with titanium
steel oh no
adamentium
what is that wolverines yeah
we don't know unless at the moment it
does exist that we know of right now
i'm not into the frankenstein thing i'm
not into just like having
surgery on some just for your fans well
i think some people though
like they envision a certain way that
they want to look
and if they weren't born that way
they're like they try to change it and
[ __ ] they can't change
then they i don't know man that's so
scary i read a thing on like
certain the big tech guys i don't know
if it's amazon got you there google they
have this whole thing about trying to
make people live you know of course for
the
the rich guys to live longer 100 years
plus right quite a while but it's like
this kind of stuff where they're
re researching and doing stuff where we
can implant things into our body
of course rich people are degenerating
right so they can live forever what's
that mm-hmm
you know like right now i think it's
weird right to all of us
but let's say this is as commonplace as
girls getting titties
that might be different like let's say
you know you might be like 8 out of 10
guys
you're like oh [ __ ] you used to be five
seven and a half two and now you're a
five nine and you're blocking all my
shots
damn i'm more handsome than you but
you're taller than me and you get casted
more than me
you're changing his mind you know i'm
changing his mind i couldn't i still
like i still a little bit like i
understand like uh oh you're not
your arch nemesis in hollywood you guys
both five seven and a half also this
fool's five nine booking all kinds of
rolls and you're like [ __ ]
oh but it might all change into straight
yeah we're talking about china and he
still books a lot of roles
tom cruise is five seven yeah yeah seven
he's really strong
he's short sure cause like how short
they say like five seven doesn't seem
much right
uh yeah comparatively to other hollywood
they think you're taller
they're all everyone thinks you're
talking people want to meet me there
listen i thought you were taller
than me i'm not taller than you damn
isn't that like the worst thing to hear
like whatever
i go i have a big persona there you go
about that [ __ ] i love it i just think i
just think
i don't know don't you think it's like
you're going in to change some stuff
that you got
and put yourself in a situation where
you could die
like a surgery i don't want to go
through the pain the pain you're putting
through pain that's a lot
and and i get like there's augmentations
and stuff chicks do it all the time
i know but sometimes i go like damn
that's a lot to do for something that
maybe like muscle implants and [ __ ]
because really for girls and even for
this guy too like you think
other people really care but they don't
care you know what it's just you and
your own psyche
but you're also assuming that the person
getting the surgery cares about what
other people
know right right it's really for you but
a lot of times we think it's for other
people but it's really for you so you
guys like
figure out where you are you know yeah
that was interesting because it's more
about
fixing your own psychology rather than
fixing your body it seems like it's like
by doing
getting taller it helps enhance your own
like
mental like if your arms are longer you
can grab drinks further away
right right i can't fix my psychology
and grab that drink and if your legs are
longer you could take
wider steps well like it said we were
talking like if you can get
super human strength or something oh i'm
doing the [ __ ] surgery would you do
it
yeah like one hand super cute like what
like boom no like you could get like a
mechanical oh yeah i would chop my
skywalker
my arm off
i want my wallet in my arm because i
don't want to carry it anymore there's a
cell phone
dude we're heading in that direction
with [ __ ] barcodes and [ __ ]
really yeah just double click about like
no cash ultimately we're already
advancing we've already become cyborgs
the fact that we're carrying phones
around practically
ninety percent of our days that's our
second brain dude yeah basically we've
just we've already
i have we've evolved from what we were
20 years ago to a race we're a cyborg
race now
yeah that's true so do you want to be a
short cyborg a tall sign
[Music]
you